Chicago Chicago survivors of the school
shooting in Parkland are taking their
crusade for change on tour joined by
celebrities and gun violence survivors
like Gabby Giffords the student
activists kicked off a nationwide summer
bus tour called road to change in
Chicago but they're not going it alone
says Cameron Caskey from parkland we're
traveling around the country not only to
register people to vote but also to
serve as a megaphone for the people who
are so often ignored for the communities
that deal with gun violence in a way
that ours never has had to how often do
you hear the sound of gunfire a lot like
every other day 19 year old Imani
Johnson is a youth organizer in Chicago
have you felt ignored for years yes
absolutely we never got any attention
we've had press conferences wait no
press showed up how does it feel now
having parkland students join you I feel
like is a beautiful thing like that
we're all finally starting to come
together even though like it's taking so
long
I just feel grateful that they've been
able to like share their platform with
well it's a unified front the only way
to do this and solve this issue is
together bullets don't discriminate
their bus tour will include 50 stops in
more than 20 states over the next two
months
a lot of people think you and your peers
are partisan that you're gonna be going
along this bus tour trying to get
liberals who are anti-gun into office is
that the plan we'd be much happier to
see the largest voter turnout in US
history then see a bunch of liberals get
elected we're not going around to tell
people who to vote for we're going out
there to tell people to vote if you
agree with us go vote if you disagree
with us go vote it's been a long road to
their road to change we first met Cassie
and his peers just days after the
Parkland school massacre and even then
their eyes were on the elections that
action can be made through change which
can be done through voting that
determination was followed by rallies
this isn't
just a mental health issue walkouts and
a worldwide day of marches voters are
coming but the school shootings
continued when we met just after the
Parkwood shooting you guys said never
again
but sadly since then there's been
Noblesville dixon santa fe we said never
again no like damn well that would
happen again we said never again because
this should have never happened again
the young people of this country are
inheriting the world we are walking into
the future and all we want is for it to
be a safer better place
we have no horse in this race besides
not getting shot though many are too
young to vote they plan to shape the
election for CBS this morning Saturday
Adriana Diaz Chicago